[Music]
hey welcome to winners on a Wednesday
this week I want to introduce you a
wonderful lady called Danny and Danny
has quit her job just last week she's
owned properties for for many years but
she's recently started rent to rent
which has made her financially free so
we're gonna share the story and get the
nuts and bolts of what happened and how
she did it and the learning points so
Danny welcome to the show thank you
thank you so much for being here
you when did you quit your job Friday
last week high five brilliant and how
are we working in that job for ten years
and you hated it right because I know it
oh and I just thought well even if I got
somewhere else it's all be the same yeah
yeah so you stuck it out for ten years
yeah and then decided to quit why did
you quit last week then what happened
what was different so we started the
rent friend I say end of January yeah
and we have now three which when we look
at what they will have as a profit place
my income in April and this is and this
is very no like your yeah these have
just gone live in the last month or so
how are the bookings at the moment are
they're coming in nicely as you expect
it yeah just I didn't expect it to go
that well I was thinking on probably do
you know March April they will not be
that busy I just would yeah we had
bookings so many straight away yeah we
have for like Jordan July a fully booked
that's fantastic and we have long long
stay bookings which is really nice see I
want to talk to you about the due
diligence that you did to find those
particular rent to rent properties and
going to sort of the some of the nuts
and bolts but before we do that why
don't you give us a little bit of a an
idea about your background where you've
come from so so we can really get get to
get familiar with the back story yeah so
I'm originally from Bulgaria I came in
UK about ten years ago and it was just I
came in thinking okay I'll be here for
six months just work a little bit have
some money and go back home
but then I just really liked it and I
thought I'm I'm staying here
yeah and then I met my husband we
decided if we wanted to buy a house and
we bought the first house in 2012 okay
and then we we didn't really think about
it as investors or anything we just okay
so we're in disabled buy another one
yeah we're just using savings to do this
from from the jobs yeah because we were
working quite hard I mean he was working
about 24 hours a day he was just there
all the time well and we were saving
quite a lot yeah but at the same time
we're getting really tired yes so um
then we realized there should be another
way yeah we watched your videos first
we went through some pin meetings and we
came to your crash course I remember I
remember that that was what was that
what six twelve months ago yeah lashing
a beginning of June and what what was
the moment when you realized that
actually financial freedom was closer
than you thought it's I think on the
crash course so the first day you just
think okay yeah so good to be true
okay no I'll come back tomorrow and see
what happens and then we came back and
we were thinking oh my god this possible
isn't it yeah and then we just thought
okay we have to do this and we thought
because we didn't think we can do it on
our own so that's when we signed up for
the Academy boolean and with like the
support the training we head through
they're cutting me we just did it took a
while because I think at the beginning
we just felt overwhelmed you were
because cuz you were I mean when you
join when you come to the crash course I
remember meeting you husband you were so
excited oh my gosh this is amazing and
everything like that you told me
situation but I didn't like your job and
everything but then you got a little bit
disheartened didn't your after a couple
of months tell us about that I just felt
like there's so many different ways to
do it and we were first thing to do one
thing then we just don't know that
sounds better and it just felt like
we didn't stick to one thing so I think
that's why I didn't work yeah we were
just going from one line what strategies
were you getting distracted with what
were some of the strategies that you
were looking at first probably wanted to
buy property and do an HMO yeah but then
we realized with the savings we have we
can't really afford yes we live in Kent
then we start looking up north but we
just couldn't find the right property I
think yeah and because we were not that
close we were driving five hours up and
down and we just no no no this will not
just work like that so after that we we
had the first meeting with you I think
it was end of June and then you said to
us we were probably better hunting rent
trends because in can they work really
well yeah then we started looking at
that and I think I tried a couple you
know when you try the calls and you
speak to like landlords or agents and
they say no and I think that's when I
just thought sure this is for me and I
stopped for a little bit and you put up
a really depressing video on the academy
group
do you remember yeah you papa video said
oh this isn't working I'm really
frustrated remember that and that must
have only been about four months ago
yeah I think I don't know if everyone
has this point where they get to and
they think oh I'm not sure this will
work
yeah but then I think you just come back
to it and it goes even stronger yeah
and so basically then so you realized
that buying properties traditionally
taking savings and by putting it into
property was going to make you wealthy
over a very long period of time but but
it wasn't gonna get you financially free
fast no and that's what I was looking
for I just wanted to get my job yeah you
came to the crash course and you
realized oh my gosh there's lots of
different strategies yeah and you and
you learned about them and you saw that
it's possible hated your job wanted out
so you then started trying different
strategies but you were confused doing
big deal packaged in a bit of this a bit
of that
HMOs up north near me and you and you
were confused yeah and then when was the
moment that you decided to get focused
and
why did you choose rent to rent as your
strategy yeah middle of January I think
that was the point where I just thought
I'll go to that training and if it
doesn't work I'm not really and this was
part of the Academy right
yeah so tell us about your first deal
then you were there when I do you
remember when I was on the coach yeah so
we did the viewings and I was waiting
for the agents to come back to me and on
that day on 7th February I was in the
coaching and they takes my thing yes
yeah landlords are happy you can go
we'll celebrate it together yeah yeah so
what would the what where was it and
what were the figures yeah it's a lovely
little cottage two-bedroom cottage so
it's because came to play is like a
historical City it works really well
like people go there because they want
like an old-fashioned yeah kind of
property so they it's quite booked quite
a lot because people want to see it's in
the middle of the little town so they
want to see like the historical path
yeah and I've done it my way which the
part that I really enjoy from the whole
thing is the dressing up and I've made
it with my favorite colors like orange
yellow put a little bit of grade it just
looks really bright and you've done a
fabulous job so how did you manage to
find the landlord and what did you say
there was I have had two agents okay but
we saw the landlords when we went for
the viewing they were painting yeah so
we had a little talk with them but with
the agents I just found that I don't
know what everyone else is doing but I
called and I just say can I have you the
property I don't explain anything on the
phone okay
I just find it if I say oh do you do
company let's and stuff like that you
know yeah and I just booked the viewings
go and view the property and then I just
say well I didn't want to waste your
time but I'll just explain quickly what
we do
so you it's interesting so you ring up
and book of Ewing is just a normal
person yeah and that because you think
that trying to explain over the phone
can be difficult which is not
necessarily what everyone does but
that's what I found but then when you
get to the property at what point do you
do you do that do you as soon as you get
there do you say I don't know what time
you look around look around make sure
this property is right for it and then I
just say what the property will work
really well and I explained about
company late what we do what properties
we're looking for and because on the
first property I didn't really have any
pictures to show or you know I was a new
company yeah I couldn't really say oh
look what we do yeah cuz you're brand
new yeah but you so you just literally
register the company yeah did you do
yourself what did you get accountant to
do it and how much did it cost 25 set
the company up yeah and then how much
did you have to pay the accountant all
right okay so so so you set up a company
and accountant did that and and you paid
20 pounds yeah and then you booked some
viewings in your local area which you
thought would work for serviced
accommodation you just turn up and then
and then you just tell the agent what
you do and once you look around the
property and then what did the agent say
we had a couple of agents that were
quite negative okay let me said company
late you can see the dead face drop but
how did that make you feel when that
happened because the like the first
viewings for quite good the agents were
open to companies so now we've seen you
know that it's great they know about it
yeah even one of Dayton said I think you
know take every being being booking.com
an hour sir yes and she said yeah that's
fine we have someone else doing it okay
cries yeah and the thing is it's kind of
a numbers game isn't it some agents will
be okay some won't that we're not dead
hope and I just thought okay well fine
yeah so you didn't try and persuade them
no because like one of them said they
had really bad experience with company
lives company took a property then they
they were not paying the rent to the
landlord
yeah
but the people staying in there were
paying so he was getting the money in
but didn't pay the rent oh that's
terrible
so yeah there are lots of people doing
it and not the right way and that makes
it a bit difficult for everyone else but
yeah it does and I think the problem is
and one of the dangers to me even doing
this video with you is is some people
will go out and try to do it but they
won't have the right contracts they
weren't at the right training they're
one of the why insurances and they'll do
it wrong and then they'll upset the
agents and then when me and you go the
agents will be like no about experience
and that's why I always urge people to
be inspired from the YouTube videos to
take action but to also make sure that
you do it right to make sure you've got
the right training I don't know what
you'd say to that because of the videos
and they just try and get some
information out but I just normally say
well I think the first thing you need to
do is get some proper training yeah
because even if you try and do it
yourself and other people that do it
themselves and they're fine
yeah but lots of people need the support
yeah and of course the knowledge yes way
it's like when you get when you when you
learn to drive you can figure out
yourself and you can maybe you know or
grab an uncle or someone to show you the
ropes but really if you just do it
properly and get a trainer you're gonna
drive well and you're gonna flash a test
and you're gonna get success and you've
you've done that and the results have
paid off wonderfully so okay so that so
so that so you've had some agents that
were happy some that weren't once you've
got the property and they agree what
kind of contracts do you use so I use my
contract all the time yeah some of them
are not happy to use it the way I have
it so they change it a little bit but I
make sure that the main points are in
there and where did you get that
contract from lately
of course I'm not driving right no I'm
not like this one of the things why I
signed up for the training I wanted to
have the legal stuff yeah
properly done because I didn't want to I
don't want to worry about oh what about
if something happens and it's not right
yeah so yes Leslie gave me the contract
I had questions on facebook about it as
well people are sending me messages
can I have a copy of your contract I'll
pay for it no sorry
yeah well people will people will try
and take shortcuts and they'll try and
you know but but again it goes back to
just doing it properly doesn't matter
yeah exactly yeah okay so so what did
you learn them from that first from what
I mean I know you learnt absolutely
loads but from the successes from the
failures what would be the the learning
curves which I didn't expect I was just
thinking oh you know you get a property
set up oh yeah but there's so many
little bits that you don't even think
about until you get to that point yeah
and I had lots of times when I was just
thinking why am I doing this this is
really difficult but then you go back to
your why yeah and it just you just think
okay so yeah yeah I'm going ahead yeah
and what what's your biggest why so one
of the biggest twice was my job of
course I wanted to quit my job because I
didn't enjoy it at all
and the other thing is my husband's
working at night I work in the day yeah
so sometimes we don't really see each
other we'll see each other at the
weekend and that's it yeah so that was
like a main thing for me I just wanted
to see him more yeah what was the point
to be with him if I can't spend the time
together
sure and how's that changed now oh yeah
what what what's life like now compared
I see him when he goes to bed I see him
when he wakes up yeah because I don't
need to wake up early and worry about
you know going to work and when he's off
we can do stuff not if if he's off
sometimes in the week because he works
shifts I can't go out with him because
I'm working no I can what would you say
to your one-year-old one year younger
self so if you were speaking advising
yourself from one year ago what advice
would you give oh I don't know why
didn't
yeah yeah I will probably just say to
myself just go out and do it don't just
think about this and that just
concentrate on one thing focus and just
go ahead and do it that's great what do
you think some of the biggest challenges
or risks are with serviced accommodation
or rent to rent one of the things is I
don't think anyone can tell you the
property will work yeah so until you get
the property and you try it I don't
think you will know 100% yes this will
be perfect but of course on the contract
you have one month break clause well you
do that's the problem some people that
don't know what they're doing they don't
know things like that yes that's why I
don't worry because if something kept on
it really doesn't work which you know if
I if you do your due diligence it
shouldn't be but just in case yeah sure
it's one thing key you have on there
that oh yeah the property might just not
rent out as you hoped and for you that's
obviously not being the case how did you
feel when the first but but a batch of
bookings all started coming in I was
just thinking I couldn't believe it I
thought it will take a time you know
until people see the property because
I'm not at the top at the beginning yeah
top of the list so what's going on air
being being booking all the time
searching for my property and clicking
on it from different places just to you
know I try and get up yeah and when I
saw the bookings out thinking oh my god
I can't believe it's just really
exciting yeah that's amazing
so how many properties the rent to rent
properties do you now have and with them
David partnership with someone that we
have some properties in reading okay so
you've got six properties in total what
was what's the structure of the joint
venture agreement and why did you choose
to do that I don't think I would
normally do JV but I trust that person
yeah I know him and I trust him and I
think that's really important I know
some people just made someone networking
meeting and just
oh yeah we can do something together you
have money I have time yeah no I think
you have to really know the person and
trust him before you do anything like
that yeah that's true so so basically
have you put the money in or have you
put the time in how's it works you put
the money in and then they've put the
time in and why did you choose to do
that I walk even from my essays I have a
management company I don't manage them
myself because this is something that I
don't really think I would enjoy yeah so
that's why when we talked about in she
said I can look after the properties I
just thought yeah sure so he's found
he's doing everything he's managing them
you're putting in the money yeah and
what kind of things for a rent to rent
what kind of financial costs are there
upfront I think I don't know if it's
better but I mean I feel better if I
just buy it and I know yeah it's mine
another quality and furniture what else
if you have to do a little bit of reefer
it depends if the property is in good
condition and you don't need to paint or
anything
yeah it's only the furniture and then
mainly the bills after that but they're
not at the beginning so the monthly
bills yeah and then maybe is where you
might have to pay the landlord his rent
up front one of the properties three
months yeah okay so realistically you
know you usually need a few thousand
pounds behind you to get one day I would
that be fair to say bedrooms yeah and
probably about five five thousand and
that's with you buying the furniture
paying the landlord upfront all the all
the deposit and the fees and things like
that but for this guy that you've
mentioned with he's put in nothing and
he's got a deal so you can do it with no
money depends on the thing is you've not
wanted the time you've got I don't want
the hassle I haven't got I can't be
bothered so you put in five grand but
per property but then for other people
they can be bothered they're happy to
manage themselves they all
the furniture you know they'll be
creative and they'll put in next to
nothing or sometimes even nothing I
guess it just depends on what what
season you're at in life
so what would you say to someone that
was would you advise someone put that do
it on their own or do it's a joint
venture their first deal I mean some
people prefer to do it with someone yeah
but if they don't I just don't think
it's good idea just to go for a joint
venture just for the sake of it yeah to
be with someone so I think you have to
know the person and if you think it will
work to do it together so of the six
properties that you've got some of them
obviously are joint ventures what's your
expected monthly income if you average
out over the year 3,500 okay so about
two three thousand pounds and you're how
much was your previous income so you've
basically almost doubled your income
yeah which is fantastic yeah and not
only if you doubled it I assume that you
work a lot less now as well I only have
to do something if if there is a
maintenance issue yes they don't deal
with that so it's pretty much passive
income as well yeah so that's fantastic
so what's what's next for you then Donna
what we're thinking is save the profit
because we still have my husband's
income yes we'll cover the expense we
have so we'll save the profit and we're
thinking now finally to buy something
into an HMO because that's what we
wanted to do the beginning yeah so to an
HMO because at least then it's more like
income that you have all the time it's
not like the service accommodations
you're not sure if you have bookings or
not yeah and after that I don't know we
want to do something more exciting okay
something like I don't know maybe
develop months block of flats something
I don't know something
that's fantastic yeah what advice would
you give to somebody watching this that
was thinking about getting really really
wanting to get into property what would
you say to them I would say just first
get the training because it's really
important and then when you have the
knowledge and the support just don't
wait go go ahead and do it yeah I think
knowledge and implementation together
means equal serious success doesn't it
yeah and um and mommy when did you go to
the crash course how long ago was that
because everything June everything
starts at the crash course right yeah I
know you're now on the Academy and
you've been introduced to people like
Trevor and Leslie and all the all the
guys in the team everything starts at
the crash course so in you you've done
yet goals you find actually free in less
than a year which is fantastic so what
what what what final words would you say
before we wrap up then how do you want
people to what was the biggest takeaway
you want people to get from this I think
the most important thing is I want more
people to know about that there is a
different way of learning is not just
going to a nine-to-five job yeah I want
like you're trying to get this out as
much people as you can
sure I think that this really nice
because some people don't even know
about anything like that they haven't
heard about it some people I talk to as
well they they haven't heard about it
and I just think it's if more people
know about this there will be so much
more people that will be happier will
have more time to do what they really
enjoy that's it really I will have now
more time to do water injury I love that
well it's a real honor to know you and
to work with you and I'm really really
pleased of all your successes and look
forward to helping you further in the
journey so to financial freedom good job
I hope you enjoyed that guys I think
you'll agree Danny's an absolutely
fabulous person so if you would like to
become become a winner on a Wednesday
and come on the show it all starts at
the crash course and get yourself booked
on to the
property versus crash course and I look
forward to working with you as well my
name is Samuel Leeds thank you for
watching winners on a Wednesday every
single week we interview a success
students for your inspiration you can
watch more right here on the playlist as
a whole playlist of them - what you'll
notice is every single winner on a
Wednesday always starts with them coming
to my - day crash course so if you would
like to be a winner on a Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week